Now as a programmer, you have a certain expectation
as you add more processors to the system. Your
expectation is natural if you think that if you
add, if you add more processors your performance should go
up. So this is expectation. This is what is
called scalability. That the performance of a parallel machine
is going to scale up as you increase the number
of processes. Reasonable. Reasonable to expect that. However, I mentioned
just now that the overhead associated with
increasing the number of processes in terms
of maintaining cache coherence when you have
sharing that is happening for shared data. And
so therefore, the pro in adding more processors is the fact that you can
exploit parallelism. That's the reason why you're
able to get this expectation of increased performance
with processors. But unfortunately, as you increase the
number of processors, there is increased overhead. And,
and the increased overhead also grows. As you
increase the number of processors more, overhead is
going to be incurred by the system. If we have an eight processor SMP the
overhead for cash coherence is less than if we have a 16 processor SMP or a 32
processor or a 64 processor, so the overhead is
going to grow. As a result, you can see that you
have the pro of exploiting parallelism but you have
the con of increased overhead and you end up with
an actual performance that's somewhere in the middle between
your expectation and the overhead. So, in some sense this
is a difference between what your expectation is and
what the overhead you're paying. And that becomes the actual
delivered performance of a parallel machine. And this
is very important to remember, that your delivered
performance may not necessarily be linear in the
number of processors that you add to the
system. So what should we do to get
good performance? Don't share memory across threads as
much as possible, If you want good performance
from the parallel machine. A quote that is attributed
to a famous computer scientist Chuck Thacker
comes to mind, shared memory machines scale well
when you don't share memory. Of course as
operating system designers, we have no control over
what the application programmer does. All we can
do is to ensure that the users share
data structures is kept to a minimum and
the implementation of the oppressing system caught itself.
You will see how relevant Chuck Thackers quote is as we visit operating
system synchronization, communication and scheduling algotithums and
more generally. The structure of the operating
system itself in this lesson. See if you can remind yourself of this
quote, and how often it permeates our discussion as we go through this lesson.